this may look like just another car
factory but it's actually a new micro
Factory manned by autonomous robot dogs
and robotic arms monitored by
AI it's designed to change the way cars
are produced and it's been built in the
heart of one of the smallest and most
expensive countries in the world
Singapore typically car manufacturers
don't build car factories in dense Urban
cities like Singapore but here it's it's
going to be different for most car
factories robots are going to do a lot
of the manufacturing and it's going to
be a much more flexible model
microfactories reinvent the way cars are
made by automating most of the process
and building them in a Cell rather than
along a production line This Could Be
the future in which we talk in a couple
of years from now microfactories are one
of the biggest changes to car making in
a generation and if the concept is
proven it could shape the future of the
industry
for over a 100 years cars have been
built in large plants manned by hundreds
of workers the trend has been towards
building bigger factories Tesla's Giga
Factory facility located near Austin
Texas covers more than 10 million square
ft of factory floor space and has the
capacity to build more than 250,000
Vehicles a year by comparison hund's new
microfactory Singapore stands just over
935,000 ft the car makers to the plant
could produce up to 30,000 cars a year
Hyundai has pushed aside the traditional
assembly process to allow for a much
smaller footprint behind me there are
robots that are putting together the
final finishing touches on a car
typically in a more conventional
manufacturing process that would
actually largely be done by humans it
would be done in a long assembly line
which doesn't allow for much
customization in traditional Auto
factories Vehicles travel along a linear
path and parts are installed along an
assembly line while the procedure feed
is increasingly automated the basic
process hasn't significantly changed
here it's different it's a cell-based
model which means that there are
different cells around the factory FL
where that are focused on different
tasks and uh that actually allows for a
lot more Automation in each cell robots
are tasked with installing several
components of the car before it's moved
to the next Zone cells can be modified
with different instructions from
installing Parts in an identical car
design to assembling a different vehicle
alog together Hundai says that more than
50% of the manufacturing process at a
Singapore microfactory is done by robots
automated ground Vehicles move the cars
around the
factory while four-legged robots
equipped with AI cameras Monitor and
analyze the assembling issues identified
by the robot dogs are then fixed by
human workers even though we're a small
Factory we're producing cars as a mass
manufacturer so what allows us to do
that is the usage of flexible Automation
and a large portion of systems
intelligence behind to orchestrate the
manufacturing Hundai says because
production is highly automated only
about 100 workers would be needed to
produce the plant's capacity of 30,000
cars per year that means a worker at the
microfactory could produce two to three
times the number of cars compared to a
person in a traditional Factory for sure
we will still need large scale factories
we will still need to produce as many
cars as possible in the most effective
way when it comes to overall Mobility
but we feel that the answer is not only
that and that in an urban environment
having a smaller Factory that allows us
to produce as many different types of
Mobility devices in a cost- effective
way is absolutely critical Hyundai's
plant in Singapore is the country's
first autoa factory in over 40 years
while microfactories could allow
wealthier countries to rebuild
manufacturing Industries the move toward
greater automation will mean fewer
manual jobs for workers in a typical
assembly plant you would think for the
assembly operation of high single digit
to Lo double digit percentage of
automation of automated tasks we are at
around 50% already when it comes to
Logistics the provision um at the right
time of the of the right part to the
right cell is again something where
we've automated over 60% already uh it's
also in very low double digit in other
factories it's essentially
manual microfactories are largely on
tested ground for the Auto industry
arrival an EV startup producing Vans has
committed to manufacturing their
vehicles out of microfactories however
the company has only delivered a small
number of the vehicles at forecasted out
of its plant in the UK arrival has
struggled to ramp up production and have
pushed back a planed second microfactory
in the US for now Hundai says it's the
only major car maker to start building
Vehicles out of one
we have a thesis for the future of
Mobility as we test the market if we
realize that this is right you could see
smart Urban Mobility hubs in many
different Urban environments while the
concept behind microfactories remains
unproven at a mass scale they provide a
glimpse into what car making could look
like as the industry heads towards a
future that is more
automated